Chuck yes got another one for you uh-oh
oh when I'm trying to trying to bring
bring wisdom and enlightenment to you I
love the wisdom and enlightenment it's
just that I never know what to expect
where he's coming from or where it's
gonna come from this one is I got earth
all right I all manner of spheres in my
office yes this is a moment let me yank
this off it's my favorite planet it's my
favorite planet too oh good yeah the
difference is of course in space it
doesn't look like this because in space
there are no color-coded country in
space there is ocean and land and clouds
nice and as as nature intended earth to
look it's funny how it works out that
way so I just wanted to impress upon you
how smooth Earth actually is okay we
think of it as well how could it be
smooth it's got hills and mountains
valleys valleys and and oceans and
trenches in the ocean that's right and
all this and so and even this globe
itself it has bumps on it does all right
so let's go to the the biggest bump
range there would be like just above
India and Nepal okay we get the
Himalayas last right so you feel that
okay all right so there it is right so
they're trying to tell you yeah earth is
not smooth last about this is where the
China and so it's not only there you get
it in like the Apennines and the and the
Rocky Mountains are over here of course
in the United States and it's not
slightly high as high the Appalachian
the Appalachian Mountains of course
right so we get a little bump some are
bigger than others okay right so they're
just trying to give you the essence of
the fact that earth is not smooth yeah
but I'm telling you earth is smooth
okay earth is so smooth so how smooth is
that that if you were some giant and
your finger was actually this big right
relative to earth okay if you close your
eyes and rubbed your finger across earth
right it would be one of the smoothest
things you ever touched so you're saying
that we wouldn't feel these little
representations let me tell you why I
don't think so okay okay first of all
the actual height of these mountains if
earth were this size mm-hmm would be
about the height of the
the depth of your fingerprint oh wow
and that's nothing that's nothing right
that's nothing and so therefore what how
much are they lying to you here I will
tell you okay okay so you know how high
Mount Everest is okay you know huh no I
don't know okay I know it's high I know
the actual you can't just recite 20,000
feet 28,000 feet above sea level
okay not not above the land around it
right above sea level
okay okay all right so this bump oh by
20,000 feet how many miles is that you
know five and a half maybe five and a
half six miles right somewhere in there
in there five between five and six miles
right if you calculate how big this bump
would be given the size of the earth be
83 miles high this bump yes that's
pretty wild
okay right 83 months 83 miles yeah yeah
yeah so this is lyin to you right and
almost all geologic globes that give you
the bumps in the ridges and I think
they're lions it's a little exaggerated
a lot exactly exactly a lot exaggerated
mm-hmm so this feeds our belief that
somehow earth is a very trained place
right not only that what is the highest
point on earth surface uh above sea
level that would be where that ago
where'd you go there you go that'd be
Mount Everest you know the lowest point
on Earth's surface the trench trench
let's go around to the trench or I could
have gone the short way okay the
Marianas Trench you just picked up a lot
of frequent flyer miles right it's off
the coast of the Philippines okay okay
so that's where the Philippine Islands
there so that goes down something like
thirty thirty five thousand Pheebs like
six miles okay okay so that means the
all variations in elevation on earth
from top to bottom top to bottom can be
contained within a dozen miles right
that's not a lot it's not a lot not at
all
a dozen all right doesn't matter how
wide are we again we're in miles here
sorry for you metric folks yes it's that
by the way ketchup yeah if you are in
the metric system
get with the program America he was
American nerve damage so so I know if
you only have about a dozen miles across
a diameter of 8,000 miles that's the
diameter of the earth that is small net
that is so small
if you shrunk this shrunk earth down to
a cube all right
for in billiards maybe one of the
smoothest cue ball ever built right ever
yeah
again you rub your finger on a cue ball
channel feeling you feel nothing you
don't feel nothing and as what would
happen if you did it on the earth here
so that's all I'm trying to say earth is
a very a very smooth sphere Wow see now
there will be people who will say you
are wrong because I can see mountains
and you were wrong because I can see bow
yes because you are littler if you were
an ant right crawling on a beach there's
a man this hills and down these dunes
are amazing are you just walking across
them as a human being right so it's just
a matter what's your sizes this is part
of the problem with flat earthers
because we are so tiny you're only
seeing such a small section of this huge
curved surface it doesn't come to you
across to you as it's a curved surface
right because your exposure to it is so
small so this is part of what the cosmic
perspective is just rethinking how the
world looks to you and ask is there
something fundamental about that or are
you are you stuck thinking something is
true that is not we're thinking
something that is not true that is right
and so with respect to other planets
that we know of I'll say in our
neighborhood forget her forget
exoplanets that we found how smooth are
we compared to them excellent question
so it turns out the moon is slightly
less smooth than we are
ok so they're big mountains relative to
the moon's diameter are a little higher
okay so you know why okay why he's not
as much gravity there ah what you know
what the ultimate limit on how high
amount it's gonna get on the moon is how
much the
damn ways right all right and you hold
it with just rock rock ain't infinitely
strong right exactly all right so at the
base of the rock is it can it hold it up
or will it start to succumb under
pressure and flatten out and so yeah
there's a limit to how high the
mountains will ever be on the earth just
for that reason
Wow yeah yeah and you never think of
that you never think there's a reason
why mountains can only be so high right
so and that the smaller the object is or
the less gravity it has the more you can
have a distortion relative to its size
and that's why there are some asteroids
that potato-shaped
yes all right they're not spheres right
because they're rocks can get any shape
they want without gravity forcing it
back into a sphere so anyway we live in
Manhattan which is about a dozen miles
top to bottom right that's the full
difference between the lowest point on
Earth's crust and the highest point on
Earth's crust Wow you drive that in 10
minute I was gonna say that's not
nothing but you can well yes yes nothing
right it's nothing Chuck there's the
story right yes okay one other quick
thing since gravity will prevent
mountains from getting very high right
you might ask well what object has the
strongest gravity of them all okay so
you get neutron stars right that's real
which is a failed black hole it'll fail
black hole yep and they don't want to be
called that but that's so nutri start
very severe surface gravity and in fact
let me tell you severely gravity if you
had a sheet of paper mm-hmm on it the
thickness of the paper to ascend the
width of the sheet of paper we'd be like
you climbing a cliff face and the energy
you'd have to expend to do that Wow so
in fact neutron stars don't let anything
get too far out of alignment they're a
little clingy neutron stars are these
smoothest objects in the universe Oh for
that reason because of the gravities our
gravity yeah it's almost like it's
compact you don't grab you want to do it
wants to pull every part of it as close
to the center as possible come here I
love you and if something's a little
sticking up a little do i yank it back
in that's right get in line so so do you
have it earth and it's bumps and Wiggles
okay you go the earth smooth but not
flat